at 15
15 years old you get your first
recording contract yeah that was with
mercury records
unbelievable
in the lost goals yeah so you're in high
school right you're 15
and you sign a recording contract with
the lost souls how are you not the most
popular guy in high school well because
our recordings weren't hit records they
were pretty bad we were just another
garage band playing at school dances
in those days in the 60s after the
beatles came out they were signing
everybody
they didn't explain me
no oh he's got long hair he could sing
great sign him sign him up we'll get him
but what was that like you go home to
your mother and you go mom you're not
going to believe this i just signed a
recording contract my mom said you ain't
signing any contract till i have a
lawyer look at it
mom i want to sign the contract don't
talk about lawyers there's probably not
even a legal contract because i was 15.
my signature wasn't legal
i just can't imagine what that's like
you said those early years were wild
like you were playing parties for like
the gambino family like you take a gig
wherever you could get one and you guys
were such [ __ ] you would sit there
and try to make out with all their
daughters
and you and they would have killed you i
mean who knows what you're doing
we had no idea who these people were
they they kept asking us to play at
their parties they lived in queens
and uh they had a really nice house in
queens in in a typical queen's
development
and in the house it looked like
everything came off the back of a truck
it was what we call unga patch
everything was very underpass a lot of
gold and a lot of you know brass
a lot of
weird fixtures so we'd play we didn't
know these were like the goodfellas
these are the people who hit who did the
lufthansa heist
and they always they'd pay us with like
a big pile of money it wasn't a check it
was here here's the money and they just
threw money at us and we'd be you know
taking a break and we'd be trying to
make out with these girls
who were the daughters of goodfellas
we could have been killed we had no idea
imagine that have been your life oh my
god all we know is they love to have us
and they gave us a lot of money